Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman isn't waiting for his turn at the
throne to take his country in a
radically different direction the 32
year old Prince is distancing himself
from hardline Islam progressing women's
rights and looking past oil for income
but not since the reign of the country's
founder has this much power been in one
man's hands here's a man who identifies
himself as leader of this country even
though his father still remains King
this is the story of a Saudi millennial
whose progressive yet autocratic
tendencies are sending shockwaves
through the entire region
[Music]
Mohammed bin Salman also known as MBS
hasn't always been in line for the Saudi
throne for decades the throne has been
passed from elderly brother to a
slightly less elderly brother all sons
of the founder of Saudi Arabia
what MBS is set to buck that trend his
relationship with his father has put him
in a position that has allowed him to
leapfrog other members of his media
family because of the trust of his
father seemingly has in him that close
bond was years in the making
unlike his brothers the prince was
educated in Saudi Arabia he was by his
father's side through most of most of
his childhood and so he understands how
the royal family works from an insider's
playbook a few years after graduating
from King Saud University the Prince
went to work for his father then the
governor of Riyadh in 2011 his father
was named defense minister but MBS was
initially barred from entering the
ministry because of rumors that he was
disruptive and power-hungry gradually
the Prince worked his way back into the
venn Kings good graces and he was
assigned to Ministry of Defence where he
brought in Western consulting firms to
streamline bureaucratic inefficiencies
in 2015 his father became King and gave
his favorite son unprecedented control
over the majority of government the
Prince became known as mr. everything
finally in the summer of 2017 the king
named him Crown Prince the first in line
by passing his uncle one of many older
and more experienced statesmen he would
describe himself as the first Saudi
leader of the stature raised in the
internet age
and to someone who grew up playing video
games
Peter Waldman writes about the Middle
East and interviewed the prince for
Business Week and he compares himself to
the Silicon Valley entrepreneurs and
says I'm gonna take my state in a kind
of visionary direction in 2016 the
Prince launched vision 2030 his plan to
transform Saudi Arabia by weaning the
nation off of oil and liberalizing
Society he's listed that the prohibition
on women driving he's introduced public
entertainment such as concerts and he's
allowed cinemas to open the Prince also
plans to fulfill what he calls different
dreams for a post-carbon future a major
piece of that plan is to sell shares in
the state-owned oil company
Saudi Aramco which could create the
biggest IPO in history the reaction to
the Aramco IPO has been one of
enthusiasm and I think a bit of shock
depending on where you're looking at it
for years the Kingdom has relied on
petroleum for 90 percent of the state
budget almost all of its export earnings
and more than half of its gross domestic
product they brought in huge oil
revenues and spent it for their own
survival as a royal family in terms of
subsidizing lifestyles among Saudis so
they wouldn't push back against this
very autocratic family the collapse of
oil prices from $140 a barrel to the 30s
in 2016 caused the IMF to declare that
the country would be bankrupt by 2020 if
it carried on spending as much as it
does what this 32 year old prince has
said very clearly is we can no longer
rely on oil
to fund our lifestyles we have to begin
to contribute on a personal level to
work to be entrepreneurial to find
investments to find businesses like a
normal stage the crown prince introduced
taxes slashed handouts and is trying to
make Saudis actually pay for the energy
they consume the prince also heads an
anti-corruption commission and in the
fall of 2017 he carried out an
unprecedented purge of the Saudi elite
arresting four ministers eleven princes
and countless businessmen most were
freed after returning what were alleged
to be ill-gotten gains by taking on his
cousins in the royal family he's sending
a signal that he is dead serious about
changing the Saudi system however it has
not applied to himself thus far and I
think his own personal excesses
undermine the signal he's trying to send
while his approach may seem unforgiving
MBS is shaping the Middle East in ways
no one could really have ever imagined
and being so young he's likely to hold
power for over a half century meaning
there will be continuity of government
but without the checks and balances
needed to prevent a dictatorship the
Saudi Arabia is a police state from top
to bottom and it will continue to be for
the foreseeable future
[Music]
you
you